well fighting for mental health
awareness demand has been high for the
new streamlined suicide prevention
hotline 988 and while the government put
millions into the transition some
lawmakers say there's more to do
some even introducing legislation to
boost the hotline's funding and
resources while approval can be an
uphill battle those behind the bill hope
it won't be a partisan issue as mental
health crisis affects too many people
officially it's been a month since that
number rolled out but it's just one
piece of a bigger crisis response people
could contact the 988 number through
text or call during a mental health
crisis that's right while some call
centers in other states have been
saturated with phone calls nevada is
taking charge of the mental health
crisis response mary jane belliesa is
live in studio with more mary jane
well christian kirsten it's all about
access while all 988 calls are directed
to your local call center all call
centers also have continued to
participate in the national lifeline
network which means no call text or chat
in nevada will go unanswered
dj ooch knows what it's like to struggle
with mental health problems he's a
recovering addict now helping others it
can feel like an uphill battle and it
can feel like you want to curl up in a
ball and disappear which is why he says
988 is an important number the fact that
we have this resource now 988 to reach
out to people and make sure that they
have what they need in order to survive
and thrive is an amazing thing kendall
holcomb with the division of public and
behavioral health says the division is
partnered with css crisis support
services of nevada the only in-state
network taking calls since 98 launched
on july 16th crisis support services has
reported a 30 increase in that call
volume for initially the first two weeks
and even more since then holcomb says
nevada is one of the top states for
taking charge of the crisis response
system they've been operating for more
than five decades they are so well
established in the state nevada is
actually considered one of the leading
states in the country for this 988
rollout she says nevada is prepared to
handle calls due to training and mental
health funding part of preparing for 988
was css received additional funding to
increase their staffing
increase through training
and the benefit of css is they have
staff themselves who are spread out
across the state because a lot of them
can utilize telus
teleservices
now nevada also has low suicide rates
relatively low compared to other states
all in part of our mental health
response which includes the 988 rollout
in studio mary jane balleza 8 news now
thank you mary jane a few more facts to
share with you in 2021
crisis support services of nevada was
contacted more than 87 thousand times
and of those more than 35 thousand were
from here in our state and more than 5
200 were by text message by those under
the age of 18.